[Music]
Londyn it's easy to recognize but look
closely at a map in the very center
there's a one square mile cut out this
is the City of London which lives in a
city named London the city has its own
mayor laws and police force in fact it
behaves more like a separate country
within the United Kingdom this is
because the city's been around for much
longer than the UK it was built by the
Romans and has remained semi-autonomous
ever since to embody its fiery
independence the city's emblem is a
dragon not a bad choice you'll spot
these statues they guard the boundary of
the square mile nowadays the city's
arguably the financial capital of the
world and London is the world's biggest
foreign exchange market but the city has
a tiny residential population every
weekday workers flood into the banks law
firms and offices which fill the square
mile it's not all work this is one p.m.
you might say no surprise here city
workers having a drink but attitudes are
changing the legendary long lunch at the
pub is now seen as a bit of a macho
relic in 2017 Lloyd's of London the
legendary insurance market told its
employees the party's over
no more drinks during office hours but
as you can see not everyone got the memo
because here's the rub of it the city
had a bit of a reputation when the
after-work crowd go home the place
becomes a ghost town but that's changing
and leading the way are some high-flying
dining spots sitting on top of the Heron
tower is the duck and waffle it offers
24/7 service with a hell of a view this
is about as refined as a 24-hour Waffle
House gets but the most talked about new
guest who's reinventing the city's
reputation it's called the ned over 500
million pounds has been spent turning
this old Bank into the private member's
Club and hotel with eight restaurants in
the lobby and a bar that stays open till
4:00 a.m. the Ned's injected some
late-night atmosphere into the city this
is after all the oldest part of London
and following an injection of fun and
flavor it's growing our challenge to the
rest of the city and shaking off it's
stuffy reputation
[Music]
you